Adam Sandler was one of SNL's breakout
stars but his last season was marked by
lackluster sketches and critical stories
about the show's decline now Sandler is
opening up about his un ceremonious exit
from the show and what he has to say may
surprise you it's easy to look back on
Adam Sandler's era of Saturday night
life with Nostalgia tinted glasses but
at the time it was a difficult period
for the show in March of 1995 New York
Magazine wrote an article that was
critical of the cast behavior drawing
produ
the story also focused on the show's
overall decline in quality at one point
in the article the reporter revealed how
a rehearsal for the show was delayed so
that Sandler could film a video creeting
for Steven Spielberg's birthday in doing
this the article notes Sandler
frustrated his fellow cast members
elsewhere cast member Ellen Korn
criticized the show's lack of black
writers my La Michaels also hired
established comedians like Chris Elliott
and Michael mcken to assist in the
show's quality by the time the season 20
finale came in the spring of 1995 the
show had already taken some big hits
longtime cast members like Mike Myers
and Al Franken had already departed
mid-season while newcomer Janine
garafalo quit because she wasn't getting
enough screen time when David dukov
hosted the season finale it would serve
as a Time Capture of sorts for the show
as big changes were about to come though
many considered the 20th season of
Saturday Night Live to be below average
in quality there were some sketches that
stood out from the rest this was
especially the case when Adam Sandler
teamed with Chris Farley there the two
comedians real life friendship was
visible on screen this was apparent in
the recurring Zagat sketch which to Doo
Aris for what would become their final
Saturday Night Live episode together in
the Zagat sketch Sandler and FY Play
hanken Beverly a married couple who are
complete opposite while far's Beverly
excitedly reads Out restaurant
recommendations from the guide book to
her husband sandless hanker talks with
increasingly miserable assigns day and
night she
talks each word more useless than the
next for the season 20 finale the two
are eventually joined by Beverly's
Sister Pauline played by Dy who joins
them to create even more chaos for
sandless character like previous
iterations of the Zagat sketch this
final version is a perfect Showcase of
the Duos onscreen chemistry it was later
included in the best of Adam Sandler a
DVD release compiling many of Sandler's
greatest moments throughout his 10-year
on the show sadly the sketch was one of
the few highlights from the season 20
finale it's no surprise that many jokes
and sketches that aired on Saturday
night life throughout the 1990s have
aged poorly that said Sandler's last
episode played a key role in some of
these tasteless sketches the episode was
far from the worst a show could do at
the time a Sandler also starred in a
canteen boy sketch with ALC Baldwin that
resulted in backlash from viewers
throughout the David Dy episode Sandler
made several appearances that likely
wouldn't go overwhel with modern day
Saturday Night Live audiences one poorly
aged sketch from the episode is a game
show you think you're better than than
me Kevin nean hosted a fictional game
show and played an aggressive dock
worker throughout the game it is
established that sunless character
cannot read and the joke is hammered
into the ground overall the entire
sketch seems to imply that workingclass
individuals are less educated which is
likely something you wouldn't find
happening on Saturday Night Live these
days in the season 20 finale the Last
sketch featured Sandler Farley Tim
Meadow nor McDonald and Jay Moore as
five friends viewing a Polar Bear
exhibit at the zoo in the sketch more
jumps into the polar bear enclosure he
ends up brutally slaughtered spraying
blood all over his four friends
meanwhile his buddies react nonchalantly
to more being killed one by one the rest
of Mo's friends ultimately join him in
the enclosure McDonald plays a straight
man in the sketch until he too decides
to jump in though the sketch gets an
okay reaction from the audience it makes
for an apt ending to this controversial
era of Saturday Night Life following the
decline in ratings and poor reception to
season 20 of Saturday Night Life the
show's cast was was completely
overhauled David D's episode ended up
being the curtain call for Adam Sandler
Chris Farley Kevin nean Alan Korn Chris
Elliot Michael mcken Jay Moore Laura
kitelinger and moena banks in the huge
cash shake up between Seasons season 21
would add many Future Stars including
Will Ferrell and Daryl Hammond
unfortunately the departure of Sandler
and Farley wasn't mutual as the two were
fired because Executives NBC didn't like
them Sandler later describes learning
about his firing from his manager
telling Howard Stern about it years
later I'm not good at saying goodbye but
but but
seriously they had to get rid of me some
sza learned soon after that Farley had
also been fired and recalled being
bitter about having to leave however he
now realizes the decision wasn't up to
Saturday Night Live producer La Michaels
although Sandler would quickly move on
from Saturday Night Live to pursue a
movie career Chris Farley returned three
seasons later in 1997 to host the show
and the new Chris okay fellas however
the episode end ended up being a tragic
moment in the show's history as Farley
died only 2 months later although he was
disappointed about it at the time Adam
Sandler's firing from Saturday Night
Life ended up being a blessing in
disguise that same year he stared in
Billy Madison the film was moderately
successful and eventually became a cult
classic stop looking at me Swan in the
late '90s Sandler followed up Billy
Madison with more films that slowly
became commercial hits including Happy
Gilmore the water boy and The Wedding
Singer the latter of which was his first
of three romcoms co-starring Drew
Barrymore as the 2000s rolled around
Sandler quickly became one of the
biggest movie stars on the planet
churning out box office hits like click
and grown-ups along the way Sandler
proved that alongside his usual runchy
slapstick comedy he was also capable of
appearing in dramatic films like punch
drunk love and funny people however
Sandler was still not immune to
criticism in this era of his career
either many of the films he sted in over
the years have received a poor critical
ception including Jack and Jill and
that's my boy although his more recently
acclaimed films and return to standup
comedy have restored Sandler's Goodwill
with audiences the comedian still
carried on the negative reaction to his
sense of humor from his Saturday Night
Live days the passage of time often
brings maturity which has clearly been
the case for Adam Sandler Sandler
ultimately soften towards Saturday night
life losing the bitterness he had
towards NBC for firing him and Farley in
the mid90s however Sandler attributes
his attitude at the time to Ego telling
AARP in 2022 I didn't always see clearly
then I wanted to be a big comedian like
Eddie Murphy like Rodney Dangerfield for
a long time Sandler's mixed feelings
towards the show also prevented him from
hosting drawing an appearance on nor
McDonald's podcast he scoffed at the
suggestion of returning to host the show
believing himself to be too old around
the same time Sandler also began to
understand that his and Farley's firing
was somewhat meant to be as their time
on the show had naturally come to an end
although Sandler expressed hesitance
towards hosting Saturday Night Live in
the past he changed his mind and decided
to accept the invitation in 2019 I had
some of the best years of my life here
Saturday Night Live fans of all ages
highly anticipated the episode's airing
considering that Sandler had not hosted
since his firing in 1995 during the
opening monologue Sanda pulled a bold
move and he serated the audience with a
song about how he was fired from
Saturday Night Live he even invited
Chris Rock On Stage to join him the
episode certainly felt like a homecoming
for Sun who reprised Opera man once
again during Weekend Update he also got
to face impressions of himself in the
sketch Sandler Family Reunion aside from
marges to sandless past the comedian
also appeared in sketches that have had
their own life among current day
Saturday Night Live audiences the meem
worthy ramano tours feature Sandler as a
man promoting tours of Italy who advises
unhappy people that his tours will not
improve their lives in the retick sketch
Sandler is an old man giving advice to
his son about erectile dysfunction
however the pill that he offers is son
maybe a cover up for something more
kinky in the bedroom it's a pill it's a
pill Lemonade's amazing don't put your
mouth on there the most memorable moment
of Sandler Saturday Night Live hosting
debut came during the end of the show in
this sketch Sandler stood on stage alone
with a guitar singing a song dedicated
to his friend Chris Farley the song
originally made its debut in sandless
stand-up routine appearing as the climax
of his Netflix special 100% fresh in
2018 however performing it in studio 8h
was a much different experience for the
comedian after the show ended Sandler
described the rehearsal process of fy's
song as difficult considering he had to
perform it next to a slideshow of
Farley's personal photos and highlights
from SNL he spoke about his emotional
reaction to the performance on The Dan
Patrick Show I was like oh man I got to
prepare for this for the show to try not
to you know break down not only did
Sandler make it through but The Song
Remains one of the most heartfelt
moments of the show's entire run even
Jimmy Fallon who made a cameo in Sandler
Family Reunion spoke about watching the
moments in person on The Tonight Show
the following week you don't realize it
when you're there on S live for whatever
Seasons you are there you hang out more
than your family it's a good thing Adam
Sandler got his Saturday night life
hosting debut out of the way as less
than a year later the world went on
lockdown due to the co 19 pandemic after
Nationwide stay-at-home orders for
Saturday Night Live to hold production
the casting crew reunited over Zoom to
create three SNL at home episodes in
these episod cast members self produced
sketches with huge talents like Brad p
and Kristen wig appearing in some of
them let's do this among those cameos
was Sandler who teamed up with Pete
Davidson for the song stuck in the house
which was about adhering to quarantine
guidelines Sandler's family also appears
in the video as does Rob Schneider
Entertainment Weekly called the song an
instant classic after its Premiere and
it was later made available to stream on
services like Spotify and apple music
during the SNL at home era s also made a
more serious Cameo paying tribute to how
Wilner Wilner was the music producer at
Saturday Night Live who died from coid
the tribute recruited Sandler along with
many other former cast members including
Fred armson and Maya Rudolph to speak
about the impact Winer had on them it
was another moment where Saturday Night
Live cast members and Veterans could
come together to pay tribute to someone
who helped make so many people laugh
over the
years